okay this okay it is your undercover
done he's dead all right
we need to send the message that drugs
will not be tolerated listen up
Washington wants to make the biggest
bust in US history Pablo Escobar and his
main distributor Roberto
Elkanah are you kidding me responsible
for 80% of the product flooding into the
country promise me this is the last time
a couple of team changes Mazer your with
Abreu dude's nuts I know these people
you got to play with them you got a
drink with that you got to do whatever
you got to do make meet your soon-to-be
wife damn I need a fiance how many
undercover says she died it's a first
one but she was at the top of her class
you don't have to worry about me
I'm a big girl one wrong word here we go
one slip
my friends welcome to the United States
in my business nothing whatever comes in
the absence of trust
without it there's no loyalty
there is no loyalty the never ends well
this was an audition you got the part
come on man go
you drove this